looks pretty good what can I say bed
when you don't feel like do you have a
hard time getting out of bed in the
morning well I don't so in this video
I'm gonna teach you how to be less like
you and more like me that's not true I
still struggle occasionally to get out
of bed in the morning but after learning
these five tips I'm a lot better at it
surprisingly I didn't think that I could
be someone who could just spring out of
bed in the morning and just get to work
but these five tips have helped me
immensely and I would consider myself a
morning person now it's crazy so if
you're interested in becoming a morning
person or getting out of bed more easily
the most important thing that you need
to take into account is that you need a
reason to do it you need to find your
reason why you want to start waking up
early maybe that's you want to have more
time in the day maybe you find that
you're more productive in the morning
when you actually wake up maybe it's
because you have a lot of work you need
to get done during the day and you want
to free up your evenings for friends and
family and the fun stuff that you want
to do that was actually my reason why I
started waking up early it's cuz I do a
lot of video work and I would find that
often times I'd you know I'd have so
much schoolwork so much video work so
many personal errands I had to run by
the time the evening rolled around my
friends would be like hey Joey do you
want to go do something and I would
almost always say I got this thing I got
this assignment like this video to edit
and it gets old quick and your friends
stop calling you to do stuff and it's
pretty depressing so once you find your
reason that you want to start waking up
early you can follow these five tips to
make that process easier tip number one
is don't use your phone as an alarm
clock this is bad for a number of
reasons and the main one is that when
you wake up in the morning and you grab
your phone what's in your hand when you
wake up it's a distraction device
there's Instagram Facebook and whatever
the heck you do on your phone right
they're greeting you into the world you
don't want that and it certainly won't
help you spring out of bed and get on
with your life
the second reason is that if you were
using your phone as an alarm clock
there's a good chance that you are using
it before you went to sleep and science
is showing that that is a significant
contributor to a lack of quality in your
sleep even if you say to yourself wow
that's nice Joey
that's nice science
I use my phone before bed and I still
fall asleep just fine you're not dumb
maybe you are actually that's
certifiably absurd science shows that
when you use your phone before you sleep
releases cortisol in your brain which is
the stress hormone which really affects
the quality of sleep you don't want to
be stressed out when you're trying to
fall into deep sleep that's all
subliminal so if you think you can fall
asleep just fine with your phone that
might be the case but it's not very good
sleep the solution to that is to unplug
your phone charger from next to your
nightstand move it to the end of the
room or even to another room that sounds
absurd in this day and age but you have
to make sacrifices if you want to
succeed I think that's what they say and
then you have to buy a dedicated alarm
clock take a look at how sexy and just
minimalist and beautiful this looks I'll
throw out Amazon affiliate link in the
description so you can get your copy of
that and just give me money in the
process
tip number two is to wake up at the same
time every morning even on the weekends
you want to create your own sleep
rhythms your body's internal clock loves
that and when it knows it's time to wake
up it will give you the energy it needs
to wake up if it's consistent but if
your sleep schedules like completely
turbulent and all over the place your
internal clock has no idea what's up so
it's just gonna guess and often it
misses the mark which is why you feel
like crap in the morning but a lot of
people will argue but what if I only get
like three hours of sleep do I still
have to wake up at 7:30 my answer to
them is why are you up so late you
should be more organized than that my
other answer to that is that should be
an exception like you shouldn't be doing
that all the time try as far as you can
if you have to supplement with power
naps throughout the day that's
encouraged but I'm talking about ideals
here as just about to talk in my
experience having a fixed wake-up time
takes about a week to get used to
you'll start waking up at the same time
every morning and realize that your
body's not providing you with that
energy but it'll get easier and easier
as time goes on in about a week to two
weeks later gonna really start to get
used to it and it'll just be a
well-oiled machine tip number three is
to never set multiple alarms you might
think that by setting multiple alarms is
a security net to make sure that you
wake up but most people just use that as
an opportunity to stay in bed until you
know these
News the third alarm four times when you
set multiple alarms you're
subconsciously giving yourself
permission to sleep past that first
alarm and the second alarm so you need
to train yourself to respond properly to
that first alarm because there are no
second alarms that alarm goes off and
you have a procedure speaking of a
procedure tip number four is to have a
plan when you get out of bed one of the
main reasons I used to just go back into
bed or stay in it especially on the
weekends is because I didn't really have
a reason to get out of it obviously I
had something to do later in the day
probably a video to edit let's be real
but I didn't have to do it that morning
so like why don't I just stay in bed
until I start panicking and realize that
I should probably get some work done if
you can relate to this you need a system
this can be as easy as just getting up
out of your bed walking to your slippers
if you have slippers
I don't walking into your kitchen
pressing play on the Keurig you know
pressing start on the Keurig or
Nespresso or boiling hot water that's it
but you got to lock it in that is what
you're doing as soon as that alarm goes
off not that I recommend per se a
caffeine dependency but there are a lot
of us who have one one thing I tried
doing it didn't really work out for me
because I preferred my arrow press and
Nespresso but I had a coffee maker that
I prepped the night before that I set a
timer for so when my alarm went the
coffee was already ready for me to walk
to and it was a great system I just
didn't really like the coffee very much
but if you don't mind the taste of cheap
coffee made from a like $26 Amazon
bestseller it's probably the cheapest
way you can have that coffee automation
system if you're not a coffee snob like
me check it out you might like it it
sounded really condescending he'll
probably be good enough for you that
coffee maker stuff leads me right into
my fifth tip fifth tip fifth tip which
is prep the night before you want to
make it as easy as possible for you to
just jump out of bed and go about your
day this includes but is not limited to
having a dry towel ready for you so when
you want to take a shower you can take a
shower you might even want to prep your
outfit that you're gonna wear for the
day
the night before have a fresh pot of
coffee waiting for you like I said in
the last step figure out what's on the
to-do list for the day the night before
so that when you get out of bed and have
the coffee in you you actually know what
your days looking like all of these
things are helping you to start to do
stuff and doing stuff is the best way to
not sleep don't quote me on that
if you do too much stuff you might get
tired and then you fall asleep but I
don't you get what I'm saying if you
follow these five tips you have my
personal guarantee that getting out of
bed in the morning will be a lot easier
and you may find that getting out of bed
in the morning really isn't that bad if
you like this video go ahead and hit
that like button and if you like videos
like these in general hit that subscribe
button and if you're already subscribed
hit that Bell icon below the video I did
a live stream last week and people like
there was a fairly good turnout but
people kind of complained that they
didn't really know when I was gonna go
live and they're like well you know if I
knew that you went live I would have
totally joined and asked you some
questions and had a good time with you I
don't have a schedule for going live yet
it was a lot of fun last time you guys
asked some great questions thanks for
watching hope you have a great day and
we'll catch you in the next video
[Music]